después de un periodo de calma de varios
meses nuevos pacientes llegan a este
servicio de reanimación pero el perfil
ha cambiado
de 44 años y uno de 60 y 25 movilidades
que no están vacunados y que están
graves para nosotros así inesperado
se pensaba protegido no hay ninguna
razón por la que no podamos hacerlo pero
todavía tenemos que luchar vale hoy en
cuidados intensivos este maestro de
escuela cambio de discurso
[Música]
cuando no están vacunados de llegar a la
reanimación incluso detener pronósticos
graves
están ocupadas por personas mayores como
94 años pacientes mayores para quiénes
la reanimación está contraindicada en
caso de complicaciones
general recibieron dos dosis o El Hobbit
y una dosis y desafortunadamente
llegando al momento de hacer el refuerzo
de la vacuna no tuvieron tiempo de
hacerlo a la subida rápida de la tasa de
incidencia